citizens of reject Nation we are here at
the witching hour midnight to check out
the official trailer for saw X or 10
whatever we're going with these days we
were out at a little reject Summit with
some of the other faces you might know
from around here so we were not able to
catch this in real time but we're here
now Greg how you feeling Greg is feeling
um like that I consumed some stuff and
I'm here to tell you that uh if I didn't
tell you you wouldn't even notice
I couldn't tell myself no man we're good
we're good it was fun did you have fun I
had such a good time leave a like for
having a good time I need everyone to
have a good time big saw fans we're big
soft fans we're some of the biggest soft
fans you might find we've been here for
the whole day
John I'm trying to ask a question do you
know uh when this takes place I do I
know a couple small things they've
really revealed weirdly we'll listen to
a video about it like three days ago oh
good it's not weird I've been looking
forward to it is it that play button
everyone be quiet yeah leave a like and
we'll be talking about it obnoxiously
too long we'll see who sticks around
everyone all of you if you stick around
comment
foreign
ER
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment wow
Mexico City the results have been
stunning she saved my life
it's like all gonna be from John
Kramer's perspective you're in very good
hands with us I guess so
[Music]
after that what happens then your whole
life happens then John Kramer
oh no according to these scans you're
the devil the tumor was never removed oh
no
months at best
I still have a lot of work that needs to
be done
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness wow
this looks like an actual saw film I
know right
like the old school saw films
hello it's time to play a game yes it is
you play the game in between
the one I have planned for each of you
is very real
wow
fascinating
the only thing I have not provided is
you're anesthetic of course me
Billy you will want to remain alert
yes oh no
it also looks like an independent movie
of all the men to cheat you picked John
Kramer please don't hesitate
all the poster trapped the glass enzyme
tank this will save your life
retribution it's a Reawakening
yeah
there's a lot more emotion here than I
thought yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
dang whoa
Got Back guys we did a sketch called
Greg saw years ago yeah it shows you how
big a saw fans we are it's a crowning
Jewel of our sketch history do we say
that it takes place between saw one and
two
uh did we say yeah did we say it out
loud I think we just said that we knew
when it took place and then we didn't
actually established this takes place
between saws one and two yes all right
well John you are a much bigger I've
seen everyone at least once and a few
several times okay yeah is one of those
saw six uh actually no I've only seen it
once but I really liked it saw six is
one of the better ones and this is the
director of Saw six which makes a lot of
sense yeah because this looked very
surprisingly
emotional yeah that threw me for a loop
like visually it looks exactly like the
soft it doesn't because it started going
down a direction of where like we're
trying to get Slicker yeah we're trying
to get cooler we're trying to rise above
the scuzzy music video hyper editing do
exactly that but it feels genuine in its
approach but this would this would still
be the first time
that it is truly from like we're we're
watching this from John Kramer as if he
is the protagonist of the story yeah
we've had flashbacks like that and we've
had obviously saw films where he's like
The prominent story but yeah this one
apparently he is like sort of the lead
as well as the enigmatic villain yeah
because this surprisingly leaned more on
story and less on the Torture Games and
like look at the different devices we're
gonna have because a lot of the devices
look pretty generic if you ask me shop
but sure it's about the entire context
rather than just yeah but I kind of like
that the reason why is because you know
that feeling when you watch a prequel
and it feels like way more updated yeah
and like where was all this in the
one that wasn't the prequel it was all
that craziness because it's still a
fairly early stage for John Kramer yeah
before he started was it was saw two of
let me get a bunch of let me get a whole
how do I rent a house
let's take one room let's do every room
and they're all related to each other
yeah so having it be a little bit more
Back to Basics works for the story yeah
yeah and in a way where like I respected
what they wanted to do with Jigsaw uh
that installment but that even has that
uh quality where it is like this is in
the past technically or some of it is or
it's inspired by like a direct game from
the past that does seem much crazier
than a lot of stuff we've seen up until
now and for this being between one and
two this still feels like that DIY charm
and in some of those flashbacks that you
get and I think it is six like some of
those old traps are like really janky
and it's just like oh he just rigged a
bunch of knives together or like a bike
chain and some drills or something and
so yeah Alex was the one where he wasn't
getting he didn't get the cancer
treatment right yeah that was the one
okay six is the one where they're going
after like all the different people in
this insurance insurance companies yeah
yeah I remember that yeah and so yeah
this one you know I guess will be about
some kind of corrupt Medical Institute
praying on the you know the needy and
the weak but uh but it also had more of
a Macabre humor yeah certainly I mean
it'll be interesting humor yeah to see
how that's grown because like you know
Saw movies can be kind of Bleak but I
feel like right now it has to be a
little self-aware very serious yeah I I
rarely say a a saw trip I mean we might
have said about previous saw trailers
um but this particular one managed to
look and feel like the original saw
films
but still also managed to feel fun yeah
whereas the other ones take uh
jigsaw was was the one before spiral
right yeah jigsaw that that like looked
fun
if it didn't look necessarily like saw
sure it's again that polished thing of
like it's saw but for like a slightly
new generation and everything's like a
little more Sleek than you're used to
and this is not just a who is jigsaw so
it which gives a different approach
whereas the other ones are who is jigsaw
for the saw X is it the tenth one
I Think Jesus because they stopped
counting after seven yeah so seven eight
is jigsaw nine is spiral and this is ten
damn yeah oh this is the tenth one yeah
and to call it saw X this actually feels
confident and different usually by the
time you get to a tenth in a horror
franchise you're like oh let's do a
subtitle they've got way off the rails
exactly it's a numeral 10 yeah you have
to be at least a little confident and I
mean you know it's also X which is the
edgiest letter of the alphabet you know
that works for a saw though of course
yeah I've already gotten pretentious
about their like chapter yeah no it
lends itself to the sleazy
grindhouseness that this whole torture
genre partly hinges upon even if these
movies do care to have twists and you
know a sort of cop Thriller aesthetic
overall but that's not really here and
we're gonna see Amanda we're gonna see
Amanda we're gonna see the origins of
Amanda that we were told about now we
get to see it play out a little more
because these two don't age at all or or
because they they look like they don't
age at all but I'm sure if I watched saw
two and then I put this trailer on it'd
be like it definitely aged but oh yeah
when I mean it's growing up from being
like he's like 80 now yes what I'm just
going off of memory I'm like wow they
haven't aged at all you know yeah yeah
but if I watched him back to back sure
that one definitely looks a lot older
Amanda certainly will look a bit older I
feel like she's she's younger than Toby
Bell so that would be more noticeable
and now he's going after the scam doctor
here yeah yeah this is personal yeah and
taking away their anesthetic all the
traps seem like they'll have some kind
of surgical uh you know theme about them
and the whole it's not retribution it's
an Awakening remember that's where we
got all the needles and two from yeah uh
still one of the most icky traps and he
got some anesthesia oxygen tank and
uh too as well now we're gonna see the
origins of two that's right now we're
gonna have some kind of crazy was like
this was actually happening in the same
house just in the Attic do you think
we'll see Lee wanell I don't know that
would be cool that would be cool I mean
you know he's a sleazy photographer
but he didn't die he didn't die and they
could come back well no don't they find
his corpse like shriveled up I thought
that would be Danny Glover
or was it Lee one out I think they find
his shriveled up corpse all right I
think he does die I guess I'm just not
remembering but you never know I mean we
don't know how long he was in there for
I think we'll see Donnie Wilder
um uh probably not I don't know it's too
bad yeah I mean unless he's in Mexico
maybe that's where John Kramer meets him
and is like ah this guy needs a lesson
maybe we'll see Donnie Wahlberg's son
yeah yeah he's one of the nurses helping
jigsaws let's see let's get the same
actor back too yeah to play himself
before it's a second movie
be like uh yeah he's in Mexico for some
kind of Rejuvenation like youthfulness
treatment to keep him looking young
wow oh it's the 20th anniversary I saw
I guess it must be what is that 2004 or
2003 to 2023 sure there's a comment here
that says
I'm Legit actually legitimately crying I
saw franchise means the entire world to
me so seeing this just made my entire
week
really
hey man crazy that saw
it is such a Negative film this is a
very Bleak world yeah and as much as I
love them no it taught me to appreciate
life well that's the interesting thing
that's part of the interesting part of
it is that he does of all the moralistic
killers when it is actually John Kramer
and not one of his deluded uh you know
his disciples he's got a good point
sometimes yeah I guess so that's what
makes him interesting and I hope they
can maintain that I mean I hope like the
John Amanda stories are often especially
the John Kramer stories are like the
most rich part of Saw and oftentimes
even in the lowest lows of the saw
franchise a good John Kramer scene is a
great scene so uh this was two
it was a two and a half minute trailer I
thought it was like four minutes I know
I felt like a really long trade yeah
there's a lot in there
and there was a lot of like yeah epic
like nostalgia
you've done it we've done our saw thing
guys leave us a thought in the comments
are you excited for saw X will you be
there September 20 whatever opening
night let us know your favorite saw trap
down below and we'll catch you next time
stay sexy rejack Nation
[Music]